hey how's it going Prez my name is
let's keep playing life is strange
episode three it's [__] awesome so
far so let's do this
because we're yapping instead of
attacking each other outer versus Shark
Style
I think I've had my pool experience for
the year
let's check let's call it a draw
I'm gonna freeze my ass off when I get
out
gross I feel like we just went swimming
in chlorine Bay you look cute with your
hair soaked in chemicals
thanks you would know
oh [__] hi
good timing
oh my God
who was that
uh
in these
we have to go now
oh [__]
how did they teleport like that
maybe trigger an alarm a silent night
like when we were kids
I could use my power or just look for a
hiding spot
for both
hello oh [__] we don't [__] now didn't
we
where did she hide
let's hide in the laundry
no hello
anybody there
okay better not try any Halloween pranks
after today serious
oh [__] I heard something over here
who's here
I got I got a flashlight and a stick hey
oh [__] he got us
who's here
I got I got a flashlight and a stick hey
damn it
I got I got a flashlight and a stick
hey
who's here
I got I got a flashlight and a stick
hey
what how you saw me again what the [__]
I got a flashlight and a stick say that
one more time please
we got this Bros
no problem
looks like PewDiePie the stiffness that
strikes again
oh my God so we're gonna go back the
same way we came in girl back the same
we came in what back the same we can't
in girl
we are so invisible
it's bail
we're so invisible
well we did it oh [__] never mind
coming
I have to find another way out how did
he they not see us Jesus Christ [__]
you can't go back to your dorm now
you're a Blackwell fugitive crash at my
place tonight you want me to crash where
the black hole security officer lives so
I'll be safe okay
into the car
Max you rock we are so [__] awesome
Yes we so are
so hard
you have such a nice face
um
way better pacing in this episode I
enjoyed a lot more than episode two
this is what I wanted all along
just this stupid pointless [__]
that feels feels like it immerses you
you know
all right
so they slept together huh
wonder how that went down
oh she changed her shirt
of course
she let her borrow it it hurts
take a selfie always remember this
moment
photobomb photo hog
it's Christ
this must abrupt wake up I ever seen
feels like it like a different world
from yesterday
like it needs another one
I'd like to do something good for my
school in Arcadia Bay
I can't even submit my photo to
represent
I just don't want to be rejected
every great artist gets rejected before
they get accepted
so you have to enter a photo
even though I'm pimping the school in
town you want to torch
come on I don't want to see Arcadia Bay
burn to the shore and just say [__] like
that because I've been trying to get out
of here since
since you left
to find Rachel then pay Frank off I'm
still leaving to start a whole new life
I wish we could just hang out all
morning like we used to
maybe we should get up I have to get
back to Blackwell soon oh does the
school girl have a test today I know
this song
I'm starting to feel like going to
Blackwell every day is a test I just
need to get on my regular school
schedule again
bright eyes I think it is
yep it's free it's free I'm a true
hipster after all I knew it too well
then at the
turning the lights off
I'm so wiped out from last night but it
was awesome
I have to ponder what kind of criminal I
become
last night was only the tip of the
iceberg
I have to admit
it was pretty cool to take over the
Blackboard Jam
today the gym tomorrow the world we need
to step it up
we still have to be careful how I use my
power
I don't want to get stuck in time
conversation
sidewalk and the pigeons in my window
reflection
I feel like I should go on because I
it's copyrighted music
put some clothes on
um
glad to see you didn't blow out
Blackwell last night almost Glenn by the
way the driving is actually popular so
I'm buying the ticks now
I can't wait for us to go on a date did
my dad my hipster dad actually write me
nope he does not give a [__] put some
clothes on first put some clothes put
some clothes on first put the clothes
down
I could have hid in the closet and then
David wouldn't be on my case
still reeks like a chlorine Factory
that's evidence see if you can find a
suitable outfit in my fashion
okay time for some Chloe cosplay
hey there you go
Rachel left a bunch of her clothes with
me
she's your size but not quite my style
Max you don't have a style yet oh
you can always rewind back to your
chlorine brand t-shirt and generic jeans
you suck I like my shirt and jeans
but it would be cool to try on Rachel's
clothes just to see if they fit no
that's sweet stop second guessing
yourself Max put this on and let your
inner Punk Rock Girl come out you can
afford to take chances whenever whatever
you want to try
for example I dare you to kiss me what
I double dare you kiss me now
well
I'm not sure if I'm ready
damn your hardcore Max
now I can text Warren and tell him he
doesn't stand a chance
unless he's into girl on girl action
the phone's such a dork what the [__]
was that all about
oh man that was priceless when I kissed
Chloe
she didn't think I would
that was not priceless
that was awkward as hell
looking sick Max a couple tats some
piercings and we'll make a thrasher out
of you yet ready for the mosh pit Chaka
bra Shaka bra
I'm gonna say hi to Joyce free breakfast
let's not rewind and find out okay
all right I gotta go before I get a
copyright of this song
so cool
oh my God that smells so amazing
oh
so sad
to read stuff like that
it's like when we were kids here
nobody in this town has a [__] clue
as to what's happening
do they
I better not go in there
David might be in bed
ew how do we get out of here
where's the staircase
this is the bathroom
Chloe has had this damn dirty pirate
towel since we were kids
serious flashback
but I need to get the [__] out of here
oh there you go how did I miss that
oh my God
I worry about myself sometimes
oh it's her we know her
probably for the best if we don't get
caught
oh [__]
good morning Joyce Rachel uh I mean Max
who you saddled me well you fit those
clothes well thank God you're not a hell
razor like her or Chloe isn't he asking
exactly what you want to Chow on so they
know I'm home
isn't it a bit suspicious
well bacon pancakes dying for some of
your famous pancakes I thought you would
have missed those
ah you ate more than William
and he loved them I remember we would
erase each other to grab them from a
stack so this time you can help me with
the ingredients I need you to grab me
the eggs and milk
I like that shirt milk no problem
I love that they still have the same
refrigerator yeah because who changes it
from refrigerator woman
and who puts milk out it's gonna get
down there's milk
eggs shouldn't eggs be in a [__]
fridge what it what is this kitchen man
what is this kitchen that we're gonna go
and get a [__] chicken
do they have a chicken
hey chicken chicken
there you are
oh it's dead oh dead bird
poor thing
it's with all the dead birds
I wonder how these birds died it's
probably something to do with all this
[__] happening
that was fun
good what the [__] there's so many dead
birds three dead birds lined up
[__] ominous
weather mags weather mags weather mags
had
that
chase can you help me get this bird out
of here what the hell is that with those
birds man
oh it's there is that a bird is that a
goddamn bed you're a goddamn bad bad
scare bird be gone fly you fool [__] I
forgot to open the door that's the door
can you direct me to the eggs
just because I opened doesn't mean I
wanna
are we gonna get him out
uh oh look at the poor bird
seems kind of freaked out
should I open this window
I keep expecting to see the sky turn red
jeez
some morbid calm down
oh gotta do it all again
you all gotta do it again what
if you know that reference leave it in
the comments right now
also leave a comment if you are wearing
socks or not I really need to know that
right now
now go and die bird going down
can I ask her where they keep the eggs
come on Max find those ingredients so we
can shout out man
I don't know the eggs are there why
would the eggs be there the eggs always
come first as Joyce used to say
after all these years and everything
that's happened it's great to see you
and Chloe together again
she hasn't had a good friend since you
or Rachel
those clothes remind me so much of her
such a sweet girl
I'm just hoping she's living large in
L.A I'd love to think that too Joyce but
we are on the same page Max
I keep hoping that Rachel will show up
or even send a message to Chloe from
Hollywood
or wherever she is
there any reason that Rachel might be
mad at Chloe and left without her Chloe
could piss everybody off but her they
were almost joined at the head reminded
me of you and Chloe
Rachel wasn't as grounded as you I'm
grounded
when
maybe that's why Chloe likes Rachel so
much
Max Caulfield
jealous of Rachel
Maybe
Rachel was so much cooler than me got
that right
you think then why has Chloe been
telling me she wishes she could be more
like you over the past five years doubt
it
um did she really
five years ago feels like a thousand now
and that makes me what a century-old
there were only 18 Max oh you
only I could go back
it's not all that Joy
Joy voila a breakfast bit for us queens
and a king go sit at the table
all right all right all right we'll have
some pancakes
I make the sickest pancakes Bros
if you were here right now I'd make you
some pancakes if you know what I mean I
don't know what I mean
hmm
Kate's life was sure worth a nice
exploitive headline
time
I guess nobody Waters the plant here ah
thank you
thank you so much Joyce
I'm never leaving this table good you
can clean
there's literally nothing on those
pancakes
on this one let's look at that as I mean
let's
Now That's What I Call pancakes
uh you didn't finish it though I guess
nobody Waters the plant here
I'm glad that's creamy and not crunchy
okay so now what
seeing you again
ah made me remember so much I know these
photos don't measure up to your work Max
my favorite photographers probably take
pictures similar to yours you make David
happy Joyce he wants us all to be happy
Max
he's just not great at showing it
uh I don't think I can rock this outfit
like Rachel
you have your own cool style
the Bambi shirt that's pretty cool
I totally remember that day
I'm glad William took this picture with
his instant camera
oh
it was the last picture he ever took
he had his car out right after this
I know Joyce
I'm sorry
I didn't show you this to be morbidden
in fact I want you to have this this was
when my baby was so full of life and
lied she was hopeful positive and
everything she's not today
and this was the last time I ever saw
Chloe truly happy
did you guys have a bonding session
about how [__] up I am
it's not always about you Chloe please
it's too early to start picking a fight
eat instead
stop Whispering or I'll know you're
talking about me stop being so nosy
mother geez I can't do anything around
here without everybody getting up in my
[__] no one can even joke with you Chloe
you fly off the handle like that excuse
me I have to use the bathroom sure run
off and pee when you should back me up
now who's being paranoid the house just
listen to yourself nobody else does
I do need to get into David's computer
he's I bet David has all of his
surveillance Secrets why am I doing this
you should be doing this this is weird
for me no should it means a password
how about step douche
try again
I need more clues I think I know the
password brush
naturally David would buy a heavy duty I
can even see the combination that might
be useful
let's try that
worst hacker ever I think that was
pretty smart
okay well let's try it again
maybe I could try stepdad for the
password
oh that's a sweet photo
oh
he's so nice
that's not gonna work either
David has been dragging his head around
since 2001.
cute
can't picture David driving Joys around
with this on the car
that's cute
could be a password Here
I'm just going to look through as much
as I can
then by the end of it
even David Madsen might be an angel to
somebody else
now the car looks ready to roll
this is a better hobby for David than
surveillance
sun visor Joyce might as well have wrote
Let's Get Married
okay
we did not check this though obviously
David's parents care about him
that date might be a good password
looks like David has read this a lot
what did he learn
okay well let's try these
see what we got
try again
no way Max you totally froze the laptop
family
stepdad
nope that's a stupid password
Every Time come on
such wrong that's wrong did she just
meet me
um
okay I think I got the password it was
on the sun visor
uh behind one of the things
yeah score Max the hacker strikes again
I didn't cheat whoa spoiler alert Rachel
definitely hooked up with Frank
why does David care
oh [__] so she was hanging out with that
creep that we saw from him it's such a
stalking Kate David could have helped
her
guilty wow this is so wrong
oh creepy bastard
[__] we got a [__] I better tell
Chloe about this now
it's just one more thing to make her sad
don't I need to log out
whoa spoiler alert
Rachel definitely hooked up with Frank
why does David care
nice breakfast Here Comes Trouble David
you're back already
I have to take a nap after writing up
vandalism reports last night
what happened some little [__] ass punks
broke into the swimming pool this is
what happens at these PC [__]
colleges entitled students taking over
the campus
do you know for sure it was Blackwell
students who else would do it and I'm
gonna bust them
yeah way to look guilty Max I figured
you'd be here is that your Rachel Amber
Halloween costume you know more about
her than me
Chloe
we think like all teenagers
leave Max Alone David stop threatening
students he threatens them with
surveillance cameras so he can spy on
everybody oh [__] but he spies on all of
us here
don't start Chloe not now yeah I'm just
always starting [__] right you're a
total paranoid date not now Chloe you
used to call me a loser for getting
kicked out of Blackwell so who's the
loser now David who haven't you accused
or harassed between your investigations
into Rachel and Kate what have you done
besides get in trouble
um
I'll side with David
listen we don't know that David did
anything and nobody has any wait sorry
one second
as far as we know it's Nathan Prescott
who's the real threat so far
I would cut David slack here oh would
you how generous King Max so suddenly it
doesn't matter how Shady David has been
acting or that he keeps all those weird
files on your classmates or how you're
always going off on how creepy David
enough I don't want anybody being
accused of anything there's been too
much of that crap going on around here
lately and I don't want it in my home
today well I agree with that
now if you all don't mind I'd like to
forget about work and sit down and eat
some of this incredible grub I have to
take a dump are you coming this is Chris
yeah let's take uh take a dump together
can we talk yeah I went too easy thanks
again for defending me Max
but this is my family now
the [__] does that mean
thanks for letting me down again Max why
can't you just rewind so I don't have to
see you defending that [__]
well maybe I will
no you know what I won't I stand by my
decision
listen
when I went through David's laptop
I found pictures of Rachel and Frank
being
more than friends right no way Max she
was just posing to tease Frank if you're
not gonna believe me why don't we check
out what Frank has in his RV what's that
gonna prove Frank has Rachel's bracelet
then I have to go to school what else
does he have in there [__]
better not have anything for his sake is
he eating vomits Jesus Christ
let's check the door Frank it's so
wasted he sometimes forgets to log in
[__]
I can't believe you hung out with him
not anymore
we have to be casual ninjas here yeah he
[__] pulled a gun on us last time
shiples
okay here's the plan I'll go to the
diner and distract Frank by telling him
I have his money but he needs to come
with me then you come in and whine so
Frank doesn't see me then you can tell
Frank he needs to check out his RV and
then you rewind after you get the key
and uh and
Chloe I got this I'll be right back
don't let my epic plan get in the way of
yours I'll try to scrounge up a Scooby
Snack to distract his mangy mutt
now to find a quick and easy way to snag
Frank's keys
finally
oh my dad is more than a hipster
morning
don't ask first the snow then an eclipse
what's next the tornado hey yo
I hope not could be worse we could get
one of those California Quakes true
well I'm feeling a little dizzy now
hope you catch the big one today I
better too late to switch careers now
see you around kid
good War
I'm ready to Nosh again
oh but I need to get those keys from
Frank why is everyone texting me right
now
you nerds
what are you doing here Nathan Nathan
has time to get drugs from Frank because
he was expelled
forgot about the fishing wall of fame
it's tasty but my need for Keys comes
first
never mind me officer
maybe we all did
[__]
what are the other signs then
really what am I doing
look at all these flyers
it's so sad that nobody will read that
this is so more birds what the [__] man
oh let's follow the dead birds that
usually helps
am I right ladies
I think that was a joke
I'm not sure
more nasty [__]
I hope she finds a nice T-Bone to keep
the dogs busy
locked
how are we gonna get in
you know what let's just go away Let's
cross the street nope I don't want to go
there why not it looks awesome
I want to go there
hey how's it going peachy interview over
worst interview ever work is dried up
around here and I have bills to pay
time is money to a guy like me that
sucks wish I could drive right out of
goddamn Arcadia Bay the whole town is
crumbling snow Eclipse that [__] suicide
hey hey hey
listen Kate Marsh was not a [__] she was
severely depressed for good reasons you
didn't even know her did you I know all
these blackwell-spoiled [__] like that
other loser I'd see around here Rachel
you knew Rachel Amber
can you tell me about her nope Christ
why don't you get a real job instead of
homework I'd love to see you Blackwell
turds try to drive my 1977 Needham 18
wheeler out there well like I said
interview over
maybe I will steal it I don't want to go
that way
yes another great day in Arcadia Bay
I don't want to go that way are you sure
come on man come on man
more dead birds great
a homeless person Hi how are you well
I'm homeless otherwise yeah fantastic
who are you Max
can I get you something from the diner I
heard about that girl killing herself at
Blackwell
um
awful thing
Kate Marsh
I was with her when she jumped I tried
to save her I swear I did oh honey that
was her choice not yours
don't you carry that weight
I know
I'm starting to see that I can't change
everything
especially when it comes to other people
Kate mosh probably felt like she had
nothing no more
I know the feeling but I need to find
out who else is involved in this why is
she talking to her about that probably a
biggest Snoop than you people pretend to
not see me so I see everybody and
everything
including Nathan Prescott that spoiled
[__] finally got kicked out of his
daddy's school he also drugged the girl
who jumped sounds like you know a lot
more than me child I just think Arcadia
Bay is in trouble maybe he would like to
tell me what you're hurting
I feel like I can trust you as much as
Chloe and you wouldn't think I'm crazy
too late for me to judge anybody
plus you're not crazy I'm just gonna say
this
I had a vision of Arcadia Bay being
destroyed by a tornado
for real
could be
bad mojo is in the air this week
thanks for the warning Max
anytime homeless person
I didn't just go all the way back here
for nothing
my God
so ominous
my face is so creepy from that angle
hey I got an achievement
how about that
so what what were we doing here exactly
I think I understand
all right here we go
oh I just wanted to see what would
happen if I did this I'm gonna kill you
uh
Frank Bauer stars in a face full of
beans
turn up the brain to 11 Max how can you
snag Frank's keys
you have serious balls little girl what
the [__] hanging out with Chloe playing
with guns and dressing up like Rachel
doesn't make you cool or tough what the
[__] do you want
take a picture of me and I'll break your
[__] camera how do you know these are
Rachel's clothes because she looks
beautiful in them and you look like ass
lucky I just took that gun from you grab
your keys and let's check out your RV
let's not you [__] creep me out
in other words Max no keys maybe I could
chat up that officer or even Nathan and
then go all Groundhog Day on them until
I get the info I need okay how you doing
Maxine
I'm so sorry you had to be up there with
Kate when she you know
just know that we're proud of you for
going up there thanks officer Barry I
know you guys deal with this stuff way
more than me but it is hard to deal with
I'm glad you're representing Blackwell
Academy
I thought Nathan Prescott represents
Blackwell well don't make me backwash
this bacon you know what the prescotts
represent
taking over Arcadia Bay you're not far
wrong Max I heard the prescotts are
working on some new big land deals Mr
Prescott helped out my family once a
while ago
so I made a deal with him
that I can't seem to get out of
man if I could get one instant replay in
life
I better finish my breakfast first
interesting now we got some info on
little Nathan Scott let's talk to you
Rachel uh whatever the [__] uh oh look
Max Amber nice outfit by the way thanks
for getting me [__] expelled you Twee
[__] you're lucky this is a public
place
considering we're in a public diner with
a police officer right over there you
shouldn't advertise your rage Prescott
oh yeah you shouldn't have been snitched
on me to that [__] up principle
I bet Frank hooked you and Rachel Amber
up with party supplies nice try Rachel
partied like a fiend on her own more
than me I doubt that like you would know
virgin oh and that pig over there knows
Rachel hung out more with Frank I mean
don't talk to the cop about that dumbass
try interrogating somebody else
Lieutenant Caulfield
okay let's talk to the cop then we'll
chat later Max well that's not then
I shouldn't have said that what the [__]
now
could I get you to drop Chloe's debt are
you supposed to be a smart student
you'll find out if you do me this favor
thanks godmother but I don't need your
favors and Chloe doesn't get any from me
damn
a dead end
we'll chat later Max
okay so now I rewind before I talk to
the cop
how you doing Maxine
I'm so sorry you had to be thanks
officer Barry I know you I'm glad you
represented
let's talk about
uh the Press God deal well I heard a
rumor you were working for the Prescott
family on the side Jesus doesn't this
town ever shut up I don't blame you for
getting extra work
look sometimes I check up on the
Prescott family to make sure they're
doing all right Nathan included
keep this quiet Max
let's talk to him again
I'm glad
let's talk about Rachel and Frank Nathan
said that Rachel Amber represents oh
[__] we did this [__] with Frank Bowers
Bowers ain't no student anymore
sadly he does represent one side of
Arcadia Bay
I want you to stay out of his orbit okay
he man that rabid mutt I heard something
about Frank Bowers and his puppy my boy
does love his dog especially when the
dog is your personal drooling bodyguard
you can bet he trained that poor thing
on blood gross
I wouldn't bet
where did he get the pup Frank used to
bet on dog fights wow to his credit he
had a revelation he saved a bunch of the
dogs kept one for himself
still a creep you and that Chloe stay
away right
100 percent
now we got him
lose the dog you eat like a pig try the
floor oh
[__]
don't you just hate when you eat beans
and [__] do it
all right let's talk to him what the
[__] Nick
save dogs you act so scary but you did
save all those dogs yep one I'm not
acting two who told you about the dogs
it's actually a great story
you're an animal lover could I pet the
doggy I could go grab him from your RV
right now
I won't even let you pick up the dog
[__]
besides you don't want a leash you want
these keys right here look at your eyes
dilate
you're worse than a junkie Max but no
fix for you
okay well that helped us get the keys
closer
what you did
you did not do that that worked give me
back my cheese [__] okay give me my
keys now so now we're rewind and we
still have them
all right he brought now back to Chloe
interesting how that [__] worked
okay now we need to deal with the dog
somehow did she go
all right careful Max Cujo ahead
I should have known The Amazing
Spider-Man oh yeah I couldn't have done
it without rain
now let's get in and out
what about the devil need this Max oh
[__]
on your mark get set
throw
that's a treat treat boy I think we just
made that dog our [__]
get it now we can snoop in peace but
let's not waste time come on we have
plenty of time
the doggy is busy now but he might come
back let's see what we're gonna find in
here
the joy of watering oh yes I can talk
for days I thought my room was a
[__]
you're not a creepy drug dealer
Frank has issues but he's not creepy
at least I didn't think so until I saw
him with Rachel's bracelet
Go Breaking Bad he is heading down the
coast of Big Sur and Beyond
yes we'd be tearing up the highway and
you'd probably want me to kiss you again
Chloe we're on a schedule we need clues
about Rachel
I know just daydreaming
there must be something here
you Scope the area while I hack his
computer for info
frame too bad I don't have my Frank
Bowers Dakota ring
is Frank going to deal online now
more secrets
that's almost cute to see Frank posing
with his dog
crappy wife out here let's take him days
to download porn yep
okay this vent is loose
I need something to pry it open what
about the knife over here
this is almost as good as a set of keys
that pizza shell looks good
my blade will open any portal
ooh secrets
what do we got
oh man Rachel and Frank's dog
I don't know if I should be touched or
disturbed
wow they were really close I'm glad
Rachel got to drive this Beast Rachel
really did hang out with Frank I'm
learning more about Rachel than I want
to know hello
trouble in Paradise
I think I got I think we got what we
needed oh what the hell is he doing with
that dog
that makes me ill that Rachel posed like
this for Frank
I wrote him love letters
I can't believe she was banging Frank
Rachel straight up lied to my face why
didn't she say anything because she knew
how you would react and she wasn't much
of a friend huh
just another person who shits all over
me what is everybody in my life let me
down my dad gets killed you bail on me
for years my mother gloms on a step
[__] now Rachel betrays me Chloe
Rachel is missing nobody betrayed you
[__] you totally defended step
stalker [__] everybody Chloe
oh he knows
he knows
he's still eating those beans huh
Chloe you can't keep blaming me and
everybody for everything wrong in your
life it's so not fair
I gotta blame somebody otherwise it's
all my fault [__] that that was real
throw up and I'm not trying to be mean
but you're not the only one in Arcadia
Bay with problems Kate Marsh killed
herself you know yes Kate Marsh killed
herself she's dead such sad okay that
doesn't make me feel better about my
[__] up life get it so who do you most
want to blame my [__] dad of course
hello
you blame William
really yes I do damn right he chose to
go out that door and leave me forever
Chloe
your dad didn't choose to leave you I
know that Max
my mom actually blames herself
just because she wanted a ride home from
work
sometimes even I blame her no you don't
yes Max I do
you know what it's like to wait for your
father to come home when you're a kid
and he never does no of course not
but I was with you that day it was just
a terrible accident I wish that made me
feel better but ever since he died my
life has been dipped in [__]
you don't want to hear this but you're
still here alive with me and that is no
accident you're right I don't want to
hear this Chloe I can't do this out on
my own I need you with me
Rachel needs you
awkward
she are we crying
no
what was that oh my God oh my God
what is happening now
what the [__]
time for a picture
what the hell is this
there it is
thank you
are we going back in time someday dad
will get one of them newfangled
computers
I hope the flash didn't scare you Max oh
my gosh this is so weird this is a
keeper not
whoa hey you look totally pale are you
okay yeah I just uh
yeah okay Chloe give me the thumbs up or
thumbs down
well I might just allow this one into
the family album what is this but not
the cook William is here and daddy yes
we can Chloe's just a kid
and my fats are back in time you mean
pancakes in France they call them I'm 18
years old inside my 13 year old self if
you want to eat wow we I volunteer to
break the eggs oh she's so chippy and
Dapper remember how many eggs mom said
it depends
that's true so how many eggs don't you
dare question the chef right are we
playing the real cook here
I am when your mom is away
I'll let her know my family never took
fun goofy photos like this
what a mess we made
I remember those cool drawings I did
with Chloe
and what are we doing here this is so
strange
man
I remember Chloe reading this hello but
not after today just making a fabulous
breakfast with Chloe and Max we're all
going to work at the two whales whoa
it's all blurry here
like I can't step out of the
photographic bounds of course I'll come
pick you up now I'll have an excuse to
get a mocha be there shortly love you I
have to stop William from taking his car
today ladies I have to go rescue Yonder
Queen at the Save Mart she don't have
many bags of delicious grub for us to
feed you're ridiculous you'll be
grateful for that someday how do I stop
him [__] where are my keys oh God I
gotta find the key dollar for the swear
jar you mean your college fund geez
please
whoa
it's all blurry here
like I can't step out of the
photographic bounds
where would he keep his keys aha you
can't hide from
breakfast with Chloe and Max we're all
going to work at the two win
score okay now we have them and he
doesn't
oh I didn't know you had to get
groceries of course I'll come pick you
up now I'll have an excuse to get a
mocha hide the keys in the cereal love
you ha ha ha
excuse me ladies I have to go rescue
Yonder Queen at the Save Mart she don't
have many bags of delicious grub for us
to feel ridiculous he'll be grateful for
that someday
[__] where are my keys that's a dollar
for the swear jar you mean your college
fund geez please
that looks great
wow
You Got Talent
[__] what are those keys really another
dollar for the for their jar
you're bankrupting me
you're really good at that
oh God
so we did it I knew this thing would
come in handy how did my keys get in
here he found them
what and no Chloe and Max wine tasting
session
don't blow it because tonight your
mother promised to make us a world
famous salmon surprise that's a pro I
can't even find my keys if I [__] put
them on the counter she's never leaving
me that makes all of us
wow [__]
whoa that's creepy as hell what are you
doing
dollar for the swear Jack
you're bankrupting me
it's all an excuse to get a mocha I need
to hide the keys where William won't
hear his dumb beeper
oh okay excuse me ladies I have to go
rescue Yonder he had a beeper I want a
beeper
excuse me ladies I have to go rescue
Yonder Queen at the Save Mart [__]
hell I want to be very bags of delicious
grub for us to feed you're ridiculous
he'll be grateful for that someday
[__] where are my keys that's a dollar
for this that work
I want a beeper that's awesome I know I
had those keys right here I know it
forgot all about you little buddy
release the keys
of course
last time I ordered from spyguy
Electronics
and take the bus right
stop is right down the street you should
really take the bus this I can do good
call Max oh yeah the bus is great it
comes every 15 minutes and there'll be
plenty of room for you and joys and
groceries and and it'll save the
environment
you sold me already I'm off to you under
bus stop Joyce will love this
Max you're being so [__] strange you
feel okay Chloe I am awesome we are
awesome did I do it
you died anyway
no
holy [__] we can change because we
passed
for real cease
oh my God
she's so Dapper oh my God that face is
terrifying
it's really interesting
we're back
I'm not paying 150 what time is it oh my
God
are they hanging out hello are you even
listening wait we're friends all my
friends
Max are too cold every day never vaccine
I know sorry Mad Max you're not pissed
at me right right do you want to go hit
the girl's potty and smoking peace pipe
what I think Max is hot ah she's acting
like so weird
you cool math nobody listened when I
said we shouldn't let her in the vortex
Courtney you don't want anybody in the
club like whatever [__] how did this
happen
Warren
hooked up with Stella ouch
look at the squirrel give me the
squirrel is upset oh no this
changed
Chloe
where's Chloe
are you drives the bus
foreign
thank you
wow wow
foreign
taking a break after taking Seattle by
storm
we thought we'd never see you again
after you left for the big city
no
ever just had to close
I know she's been dying to see you hold
on
Chloe
you have a visitor
Jesus
how did that happen
oh my God Edgar
oh damn
that was [__] awesome that was
probably the best episode so far
that was [__] amazing
you stole the money 50 50. all right
80 kiss Chloe
uh not many sided with David though hey
I like to see the good in people uh you
kept yeah no one wants to hurt a dog
Frank has David's Gun Chloe has David's
Gun I don't even remember making that
decision
you damn more in the homeless people
it's very interesting
whoa
yeah
[__] awesome episode four so excited
yes this is what I needed like episode
two wasn't that great but episode two
was [__] spring was [__] awesome
I'm so excited for episode four this is
so awesome press I really hope you're
enjoying the series as much as I am if
you do go ahead and show your support by
dropping a like maybe share with your
grandma or [__] and I'll see you bros in
the next one as always thank you bro so
much wanted to stay awesome Bros